>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> John Cole: Well, good evening and
welcome to the Library of Congress.
I'm John Cole.
I'm the Director of Library of
Congress's Center for The Book.
It's the book reading literacy
arm of the Library of Congress,
which also takes a special interest
in promoting the history of books,
reading, literacy, and libraries.
We were created by Daniel
Boorstin, when he was the Librarian
of Congress in 1977, to reach out to
the general public, to promote books
and reading in the name of
the Library of Congress.
And so I'm very lucky.
I have a job that also
keeps me closely involved
with wonderful Library
of Congress activities,
such as the National Book Festival,
which we held very successfully,
much to our surprise, amazement,
and delight on Labor Day, Saturday,
and you'll be pleased to know,
we don't have a date yet,
but we pretty much decided, again,
to our surprise and amazement,
that we're going to stay at the
Convention Center and be there
to try to move it a little bit
further towards the fall they have
the Labor Day weekend that we
got stuck with, But in a way,
it was our own fault, because we
actually felt we wanted to stay
on the mall, and we did until
we lost it and were late
in getting the room at
the convention center.
In another year, next year, we
will be at the Convention Center,
and then we will settle in, I
think, and it has many advantages.
The Center for the Book also
has other responsibilities
within the library.
One of them is a new one,
and that is on behalf
of the Young Readers Center
at the Library of Congress.
We are going to be joining with the
University of Maryland in a variety
of cooperative activities.
The Young Readers Center was
opened under the auspices
of the Center for the Book in 2009.
I'm also a historian for
the Library of Congress,
and so I know that this
was especially significant.
It was the first time in
our, at the time, the 2000 --
209 years that we'd opened a space
directly for service to kids.
For under 16 accompanied
by an adult, it's a place,
not a reading room,
but a wonderful reading
and knowledge-creating space, and
it's in the Jefferson Building.
The room was made available --
the rooms were made available when
our Motion Picture Broadcasting
and Recorded Sound Division
moved to Culpeper, Virginia,
thanks to a private gift, and that
was a wonderful way to create space,
and our Librarian of Congress, James
Billington, realized the importance
of looking at younger readers
and the new educational role
of the library of Congress, which
we've been playing, actually,
about since the time the Center
for the Book was created in 1977.
And we are fortunate
to have that space.
Tonight, I was able to
take a small group of you
to see the young readers Center,
and I want to take this opportunity
to introduce Karen Jaffe, who is in
the front row, who is the director,
and I would like Karen
to stand and be known.
[ Applause ]
She's doing a wonderful job and has
a point of view that helps mirror,
for young people, what is
happening in the rest of the Library
of Congress, in the sense
that we have major exhibits
throughout the Library of Congress.
Our new civil rights,
under Karen's leadership,
there would be a small
exhibit aimed at young people
on the subject of civil rights.
For the first time, we have other
related displays that emphasize how,
in fact, the entire Library, of
Congress, whether they know it
or not, does help young people.
So having the Young Readers
Center gives us a focal point
for these activities, which magnify
the importance of the Library
of Congress itself in American
life in American culture,
and Thomas Jefferson I always think
when I think about the opening
of the Young Readers Center,
would be smiling on this,
because initially --
this is the last part
of your history lesson, I promise.
Initially, Jefferson, when the
British burned the capital,
the first location of the Library
of Congress in 1814, Jefferson,
who'd helped nurse this little
library was in Monticello.
He sold his comprehensive library
at cost back to the Congress
to begin again with the Library
of Congress, but he also hoped
that this valuable collection,
which covered all subjects,
would be the substratum, he said
it would be, the substratum someday
for a great national
library, and gradually,
that happened after the Civil
War, but it didn't really happen
until we had a reading
room for people under 16,
and that didn't happen until 2009.
So I hope you'll have a chance to
see the Young Readers Center and,
on behalf of Karen and the rest
of the library, I'm very pleased
to be part of this new lecture
series and a partnership
with the University of Maryland.
Thank you very much,
and welcome again.
[ Applause ]
>> Jennifer Priest: Well,
good afternoon, and welcome.
My name is Jennifer Priest,
and I'm the Dean of the College
of Information Studies,
Maryland's iSchool,
and I want to welcome you all
here, but just before I do that,
I also want to thank John for
his wonderful history lesson.
I'm sorry, you can tell my
accent's British, right?
I'm sorry the Brits
were so bad in the past,
but can't be responsible
for all of them.
So thank you very much, John, and
thank you to all of your staff
and everybody for just
this amazing location.
I mean, this is just a wonderful
place for tonight's event,
and I think it was made very
special by your introduction, John,
so thank you very, very much.
So Maryland's College of Information
Studies, the iSchool, is, of course,
not as old as the Library of
Congress, but one of the things
that I did want to mention to you is
that we are a very multidisciplinary
college of information studies
at iSchool, and we are
actually also celebrating.
We're celebrating our 50th
anniversary this year and next,
and don't ask me how we've
managed to have a 50th anniversary
that stretches over two years,
but we're managing to do that.
So I just want to mention that,
because I think that's an
important feature of our school
and it also links in, a little
bit, with tonight's event.
I'm just very happy to
be one of the people
to really very warmly welcome you,
and I'm thrilled to see so many
of you here, so many faculty,
staff, visitors, alums.
Many alums here.
It's a little bit of a pity
that Anne Scott MacLeod
couldn't be here tonight,
because I'm sure she would have,
you know, been very happy to hear
that this lecture tonight is being
held at the Library of Congress.
But we actually, interestingly,
we have people, I think,
who know Anne Scott MacLeod here,
and Diane Barlow will be probably
a little embarrassed that I'm going
to say this, but Anne was
one of Diane's students.
So we have some of Diane's
PhD students here, as well.
>> Diane Barlow: The other one.
The other way.
I was fortunate enough to be
Anne's first doctorate student.
>> Jennifer Priest: That's what
I -- isn't that what I said?
You were one of her students?
Yeah, yeah, so Diane was one of
Anne's first doctoral students,
and many people have benefited
hugely from Anne's presence,
and she, in fact, joined the College
of Information Studies in 1973
and was really responsible
for helping make our college a
very interdisciplinary college
and to bring children's literature
to the forefront and make
that a very respectable and
much-cherished academic study area.
And of course now, we have many
people who are interested in youth,
youth scholarship,
children's literature,
and many other topics
related to youth and reading.
So I think John will probably
be pleased to hear that.
So just having this lecture in this
wonderful place is just a pleasure.
So I very warmly welcome all
of you, and thank you very,
very much for coming tonight.
And some of you, I know.
Some of you are new faces,
but if I don't know you,
that I hope you'll keep
in touch with the college.
Many faculty and staff are
here, and let me just finish
by thinking very much all the
faculty and staff who helped
and worked with our colleagues
at the Library of Congress
to make this a nice
event for us tonight,
and you'll hear a bit
more about that.
But I have great pleasure now
in introducing Maria Salvatore,
who's going to introduce
us to tonight's speaker.
So thank you all for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> Maria Salvatore: I'd like
to add my welcome to everybody,
but I'd also like to invite
readers to travel through time
and the United States to
meet Felicity, Josefina,
Samantha, Kit, and other girls.
They can visit a summer camp
where Nate and Zach, among others,
confront and overcome challenges
that have bearing on everyday lives,
well beyond the confines
of their camp.
These and other characters continue
to resonate with readers, both young
and experienced, when they meet the
characters created by Valerie Tripp.
She's written over 31
American Girl books
and is the creative editor behind
a new series called Boys' Camp.
Books and stories have always
been important to Valerie.
She was born and raised not far
from New York City in Mount Kisco,
New York, were words and language
seem part of the fabric of family.
Words continued in
importance to Ms. Tripp,
as she continued her
education and in her career.
She graduated from Yale University's
first coeducational class
and later did graduate work
at Harvard University,
focusing on reeducation.
In addition to the American
Girl and Boys' Camp books,
Valerie has been a freelance
writer for educational publishers,
as well as other major
trade publishing houses.
In an article that she wrote,
which can be read on her website,
Ms. Tripp answers the question most
often asked to her by children,
and I would guess adults, too.
Where you get your
ideas for your books?
Her response, and I quote, "I
have concocted this lofty answer.
The ideas come from research,
memory, and imagination,
but in fact, those three
words are euphemisms."
She goes on to explain
that she's really a snoop,
and empathetic daydreamer.
Additionally, she has a good memory,
and so many of Valerie's
experiences,
including her hands-on work with
children, find their way into books.
This creates an emotional
authenticity and all of her work
that resonates with readers
of all ages and backgrounds.
Please join me in welcoming the
2014 Anne Scott MacLeod lecturer,
a sensitive snoop, who remembers
the essence of her own childhood
to white readers today
Valerie Tripp.
[ Applause ]
>> Valerie Tripp: Thank you.
I'm very glad to be here.
Let me get all settled here.
I'm actually always reassured when
I see, you know, a speaker come up
and have something written down.
So you figure it's not
going to be like a stream
of consciousness, a
bit disorganized.
So thank you very much.
I'm so honored to be here today.
It's like a dream come true,
and it's maybe all of you
who work here take it for granted,
but to walk into a building that's,
you know, part of the Library
of Congress and, you know,
have a purpose for being here
is just really exhilarating.
So thank you very, very much.
And thank you for the opportunity
to present the Anne
Scott MacLeod lecture.
Maria invited me back in February.
So my wonderful husband, who
is here, has heard me talking
about ideas for the
speech for eight months.
Eight months.
And really, I have to say the idea
of making this speech
has been a gift from you.
So thank you very much.
It has been a lens through which I
have sort of evaluated everything
that I've read or experienced
or encountered
in the last eight months.
It's really been a kick
in the consciousness,
and it's been a reason to analyze,
not without the occasional dismay,
my work habits are my more
dogged passions, as well.
So I'm grateful to you for that.
It's really led me to challenge
assumptions, and so, hence,
the title of my talk today, and
it's been an excuse to do research,
which of course, I love to do.
So I'm grateful for that too.
But mostly, mostly, thinking about
what I would say today was a reason
to think about what I do and
how much I love what I do,
which is writing stories
for children.
Don't you just love books?
Don't you?
Especially, I think,
love books for children.
I think, you know, I just --
we're all really lucky
to be engaged with them.
I'm going to make a very
non-challenging assumption right now
that all of us are booklovers here.
We're either writers or librarians
or media specialists, researchers,
editors, and readers, and
I think there's something
about being involved with
children's literature
that just nurtures optimism.
You can't help it.
You just can't help it.
The children are the
very embodiment of --
they are the personification
of promise
and potential, wacky
though they are.
And we're right there.
We're right on the spot
to witness how books
and stories nourish their growth.
I know that writing for children
in and of itself is an optimistic
and sometimes, I feel,
foolishly optimistic to act.
Sort of a leap of faith, a
cheerful trusting transformation,
that may be, you know, out of chaos,
a order and a story will emerge
and maybe that sort of, you
know, little, you know, ping,
moment of connection
with your reader.
That way you know it's really
resonated with your reader.
And all of you who are lucky enough
to be the people who hand the books
and the stories to children know
that you're changing their lives.
You're changing their lives.
Is there anything more
wonderful than saying
to a child I think you're
going to like this book.
And guess what?
Good news, there's more
where that came from.
Children's book leave an indelible
impression and an indelible imprint,
and they shape and color
and influence the way a
child perceives the world.
And the books we read as children,
I think, serve as a measure
of all the books that follow.
So I brought with me --
where did she go here?
I brought with me about
my sister gave me.
What did I do with her?
I brought Understood Betsy
that my sister gave me
with the Scholastic book, 35 cents
from the Scholastic Book Club.
Here we go.
When I was 8 -- so here we have a
book that is clearly well loved,
and you know that phrase
about "I ate it up"?
Evidently, I chewed it up.
So I just love when they said --
and I reread Understood
Betsy at least once a year.
Understood Betsy, this very
book, and also the Sherwood Ring,
by Elizabeth Marie Pope,
are the reason why I became
a children's book writer
and a writer of historical fiction.
Those books that you put in
children's hands are going
to have an enormous influence
on them their whole life long.
So I'm going to assume
you chose your profession
because how much you love books
and stories and reading now
and is much -- that you loved
it when you were a child,
and just because sometimes
the work part
of doing what we love overcomes the
love part of doing what our work is,
I want us to all just take a moment
and just luxuriate and reflect
for a moment about
why we love books.
As Anne Lamott says in Bird
by Bird, to some of us,
books are as important as
almost anything on Earth.
What a miracle it is that
out of these small, flat,
rigid squares of paper unfolds
world after world after world.
Worlds that sing to you
comfort, quiet, or excite you.
Books help us understand who we
are and how we are to behave.
An author makes you notice,
makes you pay attention,
and this is a great gift, but
I am here to say it is a gift
that would remain unwrapped
if it weren't for all of you.
I'm determined to get you
all fired up by reminding you
of why you do what you do and talk
about assumptions as
I was writing this.
My mother's voice was
in my ear saying,
"Don't assume people know
how grateful you are.
Say thank you."
So I'm saying thank
you to all of you, too.
Reading still seem like a
miracle to me, and books too,
because they never let you down.
They're good companions.
They don't waste your time.
They don't need to be
recharged or plugged in
or ruin your circadian rhythm with,
you know, blue light, and they are,
you know, just good and
rich and deep and eternally,
eternally a book says enter.
Enter, come again.
Richard Wilber expresses
this very beautifully
in his poem called the reader.
She's going back these
days to the great stories
that charmed her younger
mind, knowing, as she does,
what will become of them in
Bloody Field or Tuscan garden.
It may be that, at times, she
sees their first and final selves
at once, as a god might, to whom
all time is now, but the true wonder
of it is that she, for all
she may know of consequences,
still turns enchanted
to the next bright page.
Is that lovely?
And I think it's a wise idea
to go back and reread books,
because as Billy Collins reminds
us in his poem, Forgetfulness,
the name of the author is the
first to go, followed obediently
by the title of the plot,
the heartbreaking conclusion,
the entire novel, which suddenly
becomes one you've never read
and never even heard of.
So I think it behooves all
of us to read and reread.
It's kind of like when you
say to yourself now, you know,
I know there's a reason
why I came into this room.
I just can't remember what it is.
But both Wilber and Collins
do assume that the story got
into your head somehow,
and I'm going to say
that probably was some wonderful
librarian's generous act
of giving you that book.
So to say thank you, I want
to supply you with some facts.
The next time someone looks up, you
know, from his cell phone and says,
oh, you know, libraries are
soon to be a thing of the past.
So here's what I want you to say
innocently, sort of lure them
into a false sense of security.
Oh, oh, do you think so?
And then I want you to knock his
socks off with the following.
Challenge his assumption
by saying this is the first
of four assumptions that
you'll hear in the speech.
So you can, you know, keep
track on your fingers.
This is number one.
So the assumption that libraries
are soon to be out of date.
There are 123,291 libraries of
all kinds in the United States,
and more than 20 years after
some people predicted the demise
of libraries because of
the Internet, in fact,
the exact opposite has occurred.
Visits increased 61%, between
1994 and 2004, and now,
in 2014, they topped 2 billion.
No wonder you're tired
at the end of the day.
Despite widespread belief
that libraries are funded
by the federal government, in fact,
a whopping 81% comes
from local tax dollars.
That means the funding comes from
people that the library serves.
That's why the library's
the heart of the community,
and that's why you are the
stewards of a treasure that's part
of that heart of the community, and
those are just the cold, hard facts.
Once you've won your point with
statistics, I want you to go
on to enjoy your victory and
pursue your doubting Thomas,
reminding him that you put
books in the hands of children,
books with which they will
construct their characters,
their view of the world, their ideas
of the purpose and
challenge of life.
Books stretch children's brains
and hearts and give them a sense
of themselves as unique beings
with contributions to make.
Books spark interest, feed
passions, ignite ambitions.
They are an ongoing, reliable
source of entertainment,
education, rest, and reflection.
The books you give children
introduce those children
to characters, and therefore, teach
the children empathy and compassion.
I saw a recent study that said
reading fiction improves one's
ability to understand others.
You think?
I mean, really?
It took a study to figure that out,
and then my friend Eddy Ching
[assumed spelling] points
out that sodas nonfiction.
Of course, nonfiction stories have
heart and emotion, in addition to,
of course, providing facts that
will give a child a sense of mastery
and curiosity and give children a
sense that they, too, can contribute
to their community, whether it's
friends or family or the world.
Nonfiction can teach children
about other cultures and religions
and tastes and senses of humor.
So they'll connect and feel and hear
and experience the
excitement of discovery.
So I want you also to be
sure to point out to yourself
or doubting Thomas that these
book-influenced empathetic children
will be caring for
him in his dotage.
So doesn't he want to be sure that
that's empathetic, caring person?
By connecting children with
books, you're exposing them
to the correct way to express
themselves in written language
so that they may connect with
others and discipline themselves,
to articulate what is in
their hearts and minds.
As Margaret Edson, the author of
Wit writes, "Sitting by herself,
forcing the swirl of thoughts
into a linear systematic journey
forward, it makes you smarter.
It's like a pastry bag, literacy is.
It presses you into one clear line.
So writing teaches discipline."
Writings tricky, though.
This is me talking now.
Writings tricky, though, because
it's like asking a bunch of,
you know, goldfish to line up or
even just to show up reliably.
So where do ideas come from?
This leads me to assumption
number two.
We often hear writers
should write what they know,
and this is a challenging
assumption.
You can see where you
can use challenge both
as a verb and an adjective here.
So writers should write
from their own experience.
So okay, but I sure do hope that
that means imaginative experience.
In the world of children's
books, there's lots of discussion
and debate about who has the
right to tell which story.
Must an author live
a story to write it?
Is it presumptuous, insulting,
condescending to put myself
in someone else's skin, especially
if it's a different color?
Putting aside the question of
whether or not I do it well,
and granting that, of course,
the more varied voices we hear,
the more authors of different
races and backgrounds and cultures,
the better, isn't the fact that
an author tries a testament
to empathy and compassion?
If we don't trust our imaginations,
what hope is there for us.
We write to elucidate, to celebrate,
and if I stumble and fail and fall,
if there's a lack of
authenticity, could there be worth
in that failure for what it reveals?
I don't know.
But I do think it is especially
important to tell children, go ahead
and write about that
person who is different.
You're not bounded by the limits
of your own experience, kid.
In her essay The Right to Write,
Roxanne Robinson calls this radical
empathy, and in another place,
she defines it as bearing
compassionate witness.
I love that phrase.
Bearing compassionate witness.
She says to what it is to be
alive in this place and time.
So I'd say the very act of
writing itself pushes a child
to challenge assumptions
about himself,
and writing teaches responsibility.
Kathleen Norris says, "When
intended to communicate,
the writer is accountable
to the reader.
She must be hospitable
and welcoming."
I love this part.
"Humble in cutting
what's dear but show offy.
It's her job to focus attention.
She's engaged in experiencing with
the eye and the ear of the heart.
We write in solitude, but our
readers constitute a community."
So children right to delight, to
entertain, to engage, to connect,
and connecting really leads
us to assumption number three.
We're really tearing
through these assumptions.
Look at this.
We're going to be at the
reception in no time.
Assumption number three,
another challenging assumption
about the receiving end of stories.
The stories we give
children have to, of course,
be fueled by understandable humor,
shared experience,
common aspirations.
They must delight with
relatable mischief,
friendship, joy, and friendship.
We assume we're doing a child
a favor by giving him a book --
children favor by giving them books
that have an obvious connection
to their lives, but I
like to sort of challenge
that assumption, as well, gently.
I recently read a study
about resilience,
why some children survive and even
thrive in terrible circumstances,
and a reliable adult figure is
key, but so, too, is imagination.
Imagination.
Imagination, which when you think
about it, is a branch of hope,
is the ability to imagine different
outcomes, different circumstances,
a different life, a different self,
so shouldn't books stretch a child?
We don't know, actually, what's
going to form the bridge,
what's going to force
the connection,
and we should not underestimate
our child readers.
We have to engage our readers,
the children, where they are, yes.
Meet their interests, ability,
comprehension, and background
and existing knowledge, but
above all, respect them.
Readers are smart enough.
Boy, if I've learned anything
in the last 27 years it's
that readers are smart enough
to understand that, for example,
in the Kit books, The Depression is
a metaphor for any undeserved whack
or wallop your family might take.
Readers saw, before I did,
that Josephina's aunt was
like a stepmother, and that they
understood her divided loyalties
between her mother
and her stepmother.
Molly's dad went off to war.
The children absolutely understood
that that was a metaphor.
That was just another way of talking
about something that happened
in their lives, too, when parents
went away or moved away or left
to find a job or something.
These young readers are sharp.
They are sharp, and I believe
if the emotion is genuine,
the specific is less important.
I know, I myself, am not
particularly interested
in reading a story about
somebody who is like me.
Geez Louise, I spend
all day with me.
I would much rather read
about somebody else.
I'm taking a class, and
we read Madame Bovary.
And you sit there, you read
Madame Bovary, and you say,
she's so much more of
a hot mess than I am.
I love her.
Oh, my gosh, and I mean,
Emma, that's fabulous.
And then I sort of realized, yeah,
but you know how she's always
seeking out something new,
and she pursues, you know,
she marries poor Dr. Bovary,
and then she's with
that guy, Rodolphe.
Anyone can see a mile away
that he was a bad bet.
And then here comes Leon,
and she spends all the money.
And you say, oh, gosh, you
know, she's just hopeless.
And then I thought, well,
yeah, but you know, don't I,
every single Monday morning of
my life say, okay, eat less,
exercise more, and clean
out a closet after dinner.
And then you after dinner, you
hear yourself saying, hey honey,
do have any fudge sauce
to put on this ice cream?
So maybe Madame Bovary and
I are not that different.
We read books about people
who are different from us
to humble ourselves, you know?
In addition to making us feel better
about ourselves, they
also humble us.
And I think that's a very
important thing to do.
I think it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy and very dulling
and self-defeating to say that
children only want to read
about children like themselves,
and worse, that the book had
to be written by somebody
like themselves.
That's how you end up in an
us/them mindset, I think.
That's why love historical fiction,
because it provides a
vicarious experience.
It's a way to hold on to the past,
travel to a place you've never been,
learn about a world
beyond your own experience.
Emotion is the captivator, and the
driving force may be friendship.
Historical fiction can
present subtleties,
two sides or more, to a question.
The history has to be accurate
and authentic, and that's tricky,
because as Toni Morrison
says, "The past is not done.
The past is not over.
It's still very much in process."
And the past's very unfamiliarity
should not be diminished.
Here's what -- guess who --
Anne Scott MacLeod has to
say about historical fiction.
It's just fabulous.
She writes, "But people of the past
were not just us in odd clothing."
Isn't that great?
"They were people who saw
the world differently,
approach human relationships
differently, people for whom night
and day, heat and cold, seasons
and work and play had meanings lost
to an industrialized world.
Even if human nature is much the
same over time, human experience,
perhaps everyday experience, is not.
To wash these differences
out of historical fiction is not
only a denial of historical truth,
but a failure of imagination and
understanding that is as important
to the present as to the past."
Isn't that incredible?
That was an article she wrote
for Hornbook Magazine in 1998.
So I always think, okay, the story
has to be intimate and infinite.
It has to be unique and universal,
but, as Pleasant always used to say,
"The best book in the world is
useless if it's just sitting
on a shelf gathering dust."
And that's where librarians
and booksellers and teachers
and you and I are all partners.
You recommend a book or handy
book to a child, and when you do,
I'm hoping it will consider
sort of deeper resonances.
You know, go out on
a limb a little bit.
That brings us to assumption,
well, I called at four, but really,
it's sort of three-and-a-half.
It's that I've sort out
on the skinny branches
for a while because of Boys' Camp.
About five years ago, two really
great women, mothers of sons,
came to me and said, "You know,
we don't think books have done
for boys what they did for girls."
Which is to say to girls,
you know, go for it.
Pursue whatever your passion is.
Don't let anybody bully you are to
use you or cajole you out of that.
My Boys' Camp partners
and I didn't recognize,
and the books that we were reading
for boys, the boys that we knew
in real life who were adventurous
and kind and curious and quirky
and had rich interior lives.
The boys and the books didn't seem
to be full of promise and potential
to grow up to be like the men
we knew and loved and respected.
Men, as described by
Kenneth Rexroth,
in an essay he wrote
called The Mature Man.
"The mature man lives
quietly, does good privately,
assumes personal responsibility
for his actions,
treats others with
friendliness and courtesy,
finds mischief boring
and keeps out of it."
Isn't that lovely?
And the statistics bear out that
men's rules are changing, as well.
The number of stay-at-home fathers
has doubled from 1.1 million
in 1989 to 2 million in 2012.
So Anne and Peggy and I wanted
to provide children with books
about boys who are
likeable, brave, and thinking.
Don't think I'm being
altruistic here.
I want to, quite frankly,
better boys for girls
to share the world
worth and not boys,
as a recent New York Times article
classified men in movies and TV
as either mad, sad, or bad.
Remember that nurse who's going
to care for us in our dotage?
Don't we wanted to be a man whose
thoughtful, empathetic, articulate,
capable of self-control,
and patient?
I'm not doing Boys' Camp out
of the goodness of my heart.
And if you want another kick in the
pants, it's a passé, it's outdated,
it's old fogey to think of
men and boys as doofus is
who can't express feelings.
I actually don't believe
in hardwiring.
I believe in haywiring.
Yep. Messy, open ended, changing
all the time, contradictory,
situational based, and there's
still plenty of work to be done
in countering what is
called the male gaze.
Oh, my gosh.
I was horrified.
I went on Montgomery Public
School website to read
about this Curriculum
II that they're doing.
Nineteen children are illustrated.
Five are girls.
Of those five, one's losing
a running race to boys.
One's being helped by a
bigger boy to hold a pencil,
and one has little
ruffles across her chest.
I mean, it made me just
want to burst into flames.
That brings us to assumption
number four.
Speaking of bursting into flames,
and assumption number four
is bummer books are honest.
I think it actually betrays in
anger, a resentment, the bitterness,
and even jealousy towards children
when we keep lowering the age
at which we depress them.
I'd like to challenge the assumption
that we're doing a
child a favor to do so.
I believe in levels of
appropriate disclosure.
I think, as writers, we
have a responsibility
to at least hint at redemption.
Otherwise, as readers and as
parents, we'll reap what we've sown,
and otherwise, I think,
as readers and parents
and teachers, we should be angry.
It's as if the author takes us for
a ride in a car, drops us off far
from home, and leaves
there with no map.
It's lazy.
It's selfish.
It's self-indulgent, and it's mean.
And though the world has changed,
I think what our child
readers need has not changed.
They need to feel safe.
They need to feel loved
before they can feel free.
They need to feel supported.
Not unchallenged but supported,
and what they reach should
celebrate being observant.
It should celebrate hope and
optimism in a cheerful skepticism
that will lead them to challenge
assumptions, and you know,
I'm just going to say,
sarcasm is lazy humor.
I don't think it's charming.
I think vulgarity is pitiful.
I think people laugh
out of embarrassment
and unease at things like that.
I think stereotypes are false
at best and murderous at worst,
and we hobble children will
we teach them to be cynical.
Cynicism is not the same
thing as critical detachment,
and pessimism does not equal smarts.
So I'm reading along and firing --
I'm writing up the speech and
everything, and then you know,
at the end of the day, I
picked up American Childhood
by Anne Scott MacLeod, and get
to page 209, and she has written.
"Finally, when the awful weight
of negativism is measured,
and the failures, disappointments,
and betrayals in contemporary
children's books are tallied
together, another observation
is hard to avoid.
The literature is fundamentally
anti-child.
Something in the eagerness of
the authors to acquaint children
with all the terrors of
the contemporary world,
their unwillingness to offer
any perspective or corrective
to puerile emotions, something
in the joyousness of the fiction
as a whole, goes beyond
the requirements
of an unflinching realism,
designed, as its apologists claim,
to prepare children
for the real world."
Holy smokes.
How do you like that?
I'll tell you what.
Anne Scott MacLeod, this
is why it pays to read.
The woman whose -- I'm giving
a speech in honor of her name,
has better -- expressed
more articulately
for myself exactly the
main point I want to make.
It's fab -- it was
right there on page 209.
I was -- actually say with more --
I was a little timid, I thought.
But old Anne Scott MacLeod
right out there and unflinching.
She did not back away
from this at all.
So she's saying to authors and to
people who give children books.
You know, shield the joyous.
If the kid a chance, and I'm
going to say to those authors
and writers, I think you're wrong.
I love this poem by Sheena Pugh.
It's called sometimes.
"Sometimes things don't go,
after all, from bad to worse.
Some years, muscatel faces
down frost; green thrives;
the crops don't fail, sometimes a
man aims high, and all goes well.
A people sometimes will step back
from war; elect an honest man,
decide they care enough, that they
can't leave some stranger poor.
Some men become what
they were born for.
Sometimes our best
efforts do not go amiss,
sometimes we do as we meant to.
The sun will sometimes melt a field
of sorrow that seemed hard frozen.
May it happen for you."
Oh, now I have a Post-it note here
to myself that says "Aunt Max,"
and the reason why
have this Post-it note
that says Aunt Max is it's
a reminder to me that now
that I've waxed so
eloquent and everything,
I did read your invitation,
and you were supposed to,
I think it was listen, learn,
and enjoy, that I was invited
for my expertise, and I just wanted
to tell the story about my Aunt Max,
because it ties into expertise.
When Aunt Max was 86-years-old,
the people who lived
in her retirement home were
invited to come and play
with the orchestra of
an elementary school.
Aunt Max played violin.
So she was second chair, second
violin, with a fifth grade girl,
and at the very first rehearsal, a
woman in the front row, first chair,
first violin, turn to Aunt Max and
her music stand partner and said,
"Now, if you don't know what to do,
if there's something you don't
understand, just watch me.
Just do what I do.
So Aunt Max and the little
girl said, yeah, okay.
And after the first chair, first
violin lady turned around again,
the little girl turned to
Aunt Max and said, "Show off."
So I always like to tell
that story about Aunt Max.
So I'm not trying to show off.
I'm trying to sort of humbly
share with you the things
that I feel very passionate
about, and two things I'm sure of,
at least, and one is that we should
act as if, as C.S. Lewis says.
We don't know, so what's to lose
by learning toward the good,
especially as we nurture
and fuel our young readers.
And secondly, doesn't hope at
least deserve equal time, at least
and especially what
we give children?
Eleanor Roosevelt said
the most important word
in the English language is hope.
So I charge you to go forth
and challenge the assumption
that reality is grim.
Dysfunction is rife, and we're doing
children a favor by depressing them.
We're not.
And in so say, I feel responsibility
to you, because if I were you,
I'd be saying who is she again?
What? Didn't she write
that book about Molly?
What is she talking
about C.S. Lewis for?
So I feel a responsibility
to you to tell you sort
of where this all came from.
So I'm going to share with you
a little project I've had going.
I was raised as a Catholic,
and I majored in philosophy,
and the older I get, the more humbly
I accept my complete confusion
on all matters religious.
But in an effort to get a
foothold, I'm -- here's my practice.
I'm looking for evidence
that the universe is benign
or at least we're not totally
ridiculous to be optimistic.
And so I've come up with six, not
exactly proof, but six evidences.
So see what you think of these.
The first one is healing.
That people get better from
illness or from heartbreak,
as Emily Dickinson writes.
"We grow accustomed to the
dark when light is put away,
as when the neighbor holds the
lamp to witness her goodbye.
A moment, we uncertain step
for newness of the night.
Then fit our vision to the
dark and meet the road erect.
And so of larger darkness is
those evenings of the brain
when not a moon disclose
a sign or star, within.
The bravest grope a little and
sometimes hit a tree directly
in the four head, but as they learn
to see, either the darkness alters
or something in the sight
adjusts itself to midnight
and life steps almost straight."
So things get better.
Things get better.
My second evidence is forgiveness.
It's that moment when you
realize that the heat's gone.
You're just not mad anymore.
In my third one is learning.
That it turns out no
matter how old you are,
you can learn to do new things.
I recently said in
a moment of weakness
that I would write a mystery, and
I've loved writing the mystery.
It turns out you can learn how to
do something new, and that's, to me,
a lovely proof of the benigness
of the universe, and again,
to quote Eleanor Roosevelt.
"You must do the thing
you think you cannot do."
And the more cheerful concept
that I learned a while ago
called a Stendhal moment.
That French author.
I don't know how to say his name.
Will have to learn how to do that.
But that's a moment of sheer awe.
You know that moment
where you go, I get it!
You know, you're trying to
do something on your computer
or something, and you
think, I get it!
I find that a very optimistic
signal from the universe,
and then the fourth thing
is growing, you know, trees,
children, stuff like that.
There's a lot of sorrow and
loss, of course, along the way.
That's inevitable, but
growing and changing,
we might as well see it is good,
because there's nothing we can do
about it, and it usually leads
children to independence.
And the fifth thing is music.
Inexplicable.
And the sixth thing is the
discipline to just do the thing
and get it done, which
if you're lucky,
sort of transitions to absorption.
You know how you set and do work,
and you're just trying to, you know,
get the meaning to come out
of the chaos, and really,
all of you just wants
to go, I don't know,
just walk the dog or something.
But then you stick at it, and
then sometimes, inexplicably,
this sort of miraculous
immersion in concentration,
this whitespace happens, and
he looked out the window,
and you think, gosh, it got dark.
I mean, somehow you've made
that transition so that moment
that you can't make
happen, but if you stick
at it, sometimes does happen.
That transition into immersion, to
me, also feels pretty miraculous.
Now I'm toying with the idea of a
seventh thing, which is inventions.
Like air-conditioning and
slow cookers as evidence
that the universe is moving
in a positive direction,
but that's very dicey,
because as Lily Tomlin says,
"I worry that the person
who invented Muzak is
inventing something else."
So I'm not really sure
we can add, you know,
can really trust inventions.
So you're saying, okay, you
know, thank you, Valerie.
That's just so sweet.
And you can cite to me,
you know, opposites.
Illnesses, danger, but I
think that self-defeating.
I think it stalls you to sort of
-- it just strands you on a morass,
and I see an iceberg
of cold comfort,
and maybe I'm optimistic
because, as I said before,
the very act of writing for
children in and of itself is an act
of hope and transformation.
That out of chaos emerges
order in story.
Clarity is not usually
present at the beginning.
I'd be suspicious if clarity
did seem to be present
at the beginning of the process.
It's a discovery, and the ideas
emerge from the mist over time
with energy, focus, desire,
and discipline to make choices.
I remember one time my
daughter saying to me, "Mom,
write it right the first time."
You know, see me write something
over and over and over again,
and I wish I could write it right
the first time, but usually,
it takes many iterations
to get the --
to really be sure you're saying
what you really mean to say.
So I believe we write for children,
we want to serve and respect them
and to enrich the spot
where they are right now.
You know, curious and goofy
and intense and cheerful.
Children are, in their
lives, independent readers,
and that's exactly where we want
to meet them and encourage them
to go deep and linger there and
not to feel that they must rush off
to any next stage of anything.
We write to educate readers with
facts about, you know, animals
or history, and also, facts about
our shared culture in stories,
all the while, respecting
the reader enough
to present multiple malleable views.
We want them to challenge given
wisdom and challenge assumptions.
When we write for children,
we want to teach them
that we can love people with whom
we disagree, and we can disagree
with people whom we love.
We want to celebrate the values
of tolerance and compassion,
as well as drive, hope, creativity,
individuality, change, and work.
Work. We want to clue them into
the secret of life, which is --
you didn't know you're going to find
out the secret of life
today, did you?
Here, free of charge, here
is the secret of life.
The purpose of life is to find
out the work we're here to do
and do it, and I mean work.
I mean service.
I mean, pushing past the point of
pain when it's not fun anymore.
It's like that Marge Piercy
poem, To Be of Use that goes,
"The people I love best jump into
work headfirst without dallying
in the shallows and swim off with
sure strokes, almost out of sight.
The pitcher cries out
for water to carry,
and a person for work that is real."
So those hopeful assumptions not
only underlie all that I write.
They are also the view of life in
the universe that I want children
to trust, and they lead to
specific ideas for stories.
In fact, the smart ones of you
out there, which is, of course,
all of you, have already
figured out that under the guise
of giving you useful information,
I've actually just shown you
and tried to validate
what I do and why.
So fellow lovers of the book, I
will end as I began by thanking you
by giving me the impetus and
inspiration to think about what I do
and why, and I will send you
forth with a sense of urgency
about the moment we find
ourselves in right now.
Urgency driven by our optimism
or/and challenges, not fear,
but urgency all the same,
because at our backs,
we always hear time's
winged chariot.
Or as Irma Bombeck
wrote, "Seize the moment.
Remember all those
women on the Titanic
who waved off the dessert cart."
[ Laughter ]
It gets funnier the
more you think about it.
Or, as Rita Dove says in
her poem, Dawn Revisited.
"The whole sky is yours to write
on, blown open to a blank page.
Come on, shake a leg."
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, so.
I'm only going to be like a minute.
I swear. Well, thank
you so much for that.
That was just wonderful.
And thank you so much
for your contributions
to children's literature.
You know, it's really interesting,
listening to your talk brought back
so many precious memories.
You know, I mean, Kit, Felicity,
and Samantha were part
of our family, frankly.
You know, sisters, really,
to our three daughters.
Right? And you know,
actually, and some days,
I actually think they were the
preferred sisters to our daughters,
frankly, you know, as we played
referee on many occasion.
The American Girls, though,
weren't just friends.
They were much more.
They were a gateway to creativity,
to literacy and learning.
They were inspiration to
all who read their stories
and fostered a lifelong love of
reading, engagement, compassion,
cultural awareness,
appreciation, excuse me,
optimism, inquiry, and community.
I mean, it was a really a wonderful
set of stories that you could impart
and share with your children.
So thank you very much
for that contribution.
It was wonderful to have that.
We know for many studies
that multiple forms
of literacy are essential for both
professional and personal success,
and it starts from birth.
Actually, even before, right?
We read to children before
they're even born now.
At the high school, we're
reinvigorating our focus
on youth learning through new
initiative centered on reading,
literacy and what we are
referring to YX for Digital Youth.
As we spend the next year
re-envisioning the MLS,
a key part of that is an integrative
approach to youth learning,
literature, literacy, designed
thinking, and digital media.
Whether in a school, a public
library, the Library of Congress,
Discovery, National Geographic,
Nickelodeon, PBS, or elsewhere,
our future begins with the
inspiration, love of learning,
skills, and sense of accomplishment
that starts with reading.
You know one of the
stories I remember,
you had all these great,
funny stories.
I'm not as funny as you are.
But you know, one of the things that
you read about and sort of decry,
I think, is apparent, is we've
taken away the small victories
from children.
You know, like little
things like tying a shoe,
because we start with Velcro.
We take away all these
little things,
and literacy is actually
a major victory.
It's an accomplishment.
Have you ever watched your
child with a first read?
They can actually look at
those words and say sentences?
It's amazing what happens when you
see a child getting that skill.
We're bringing together
leading-edge research and practice
of our library, education, and
human-computer interaction faculty
to re-envision youth
learning, but we can't do
that without the creativity
of Ms. Valerie Scott, frankly,
or the research and dedication of
faculty such as Anne Scott MacLeod.
We're building the future, the
next 50 years of the iSchool
on the foundation that
you have laid.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
So with that, I actually get now
the pleasure to turn it over to
for questions for Ms. Tripp.
Do we have any questions?
Come on back up.
I'm supposed to moderate, but I
think you'll be fine on your own.
I don't really think that,
you know, [inaudible].
So while she's coming up, let
me see if there any questions?
Do we have a -- well,
it's a small enough room.
All right, we'll start over there,
and then we'll work our
way to the back, all right?
So yeah, go ahead.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
>> Valerie Tripp: For writing
the American Girl books?
>> Can you repeat the
question, please?
>> Valerie Tripp: Where
did my inspiration
for writing the American
Girl books come from?
Initially, I think it came from
love of history, but daily,
my inspiration comes from the
children I write the books for.
I'm lucky enough to have a lot of
contact through Skype are going
to Girl Scout troops or libraries
or schools or all different kinds
of groups, and speaking
to the children,
and they're very forthright about
giving me ideas, stories they would
like me to write, and they are my
continuing source of inspiration.
They inspire me, because
I always begin,
no matter what period my character
lives in, and I always begin
by thinking about my reader right
now today and what her life is
like in 2014, and I'd like to think
of the story I write as a sort
of a lovely, silky, satiny
ribbon of connection that starts
with her now and flows through time.
It connects her to this
character that lived long ago,
and that connection
can be through emotion.
It can be through she
shared experience.
It can be through hopes,
dreams, fears, but the integrity
of that connection is the emotion
and the genuineness of the emotion.
So it begins with my reader
and then, as soon as I figure
out what her life would have
been like in the period of time
that I'm writing about,
then I'm off and running.
But the girls themselves, I have
to say, the girls themselves.
Sometimes quite literally.
A girl wrote me a letter and
said, "Okay, I just broke my arm.
I want Felicity to break her arm."
So I, okay, well, [mumbling]
bloodthirsty little thing.
So I wrote a story about
Felicity breaking her arm.
It was fabulous.
Back then, they put like
leeches on your arm and stuff.
It was great.
So sometimes it's quite a direct
inspiration, and other times,
it's more of a universal
sort of inspiration,
but that's a great question.
Way in the back, yeah, hi.
>> Just kind of following
up on that question.
As you wrote [inaudible],
I'm wondering where you
conducted your historical
research [inaudible]?
>> Valerie Tripp: Where did I
conduct my historical research
and how long did it take?
That's a wonderful
question, because, really,
the research turns
out to be your life.
It's always there everywhere, just
the way everything I seem to read
for the past eight months
contributed to what I wanted
to say today in this talk, so,
too, this fabulous thing happens.
When you begin to be
interested in a period of time,
it turns out the whole world's
full of the information you need.
You just need to start
paying attention.
There was an article in the
Washington Post last week
about how curiosity, you know,
is very good for learning
because it makes you hang
onto pieces of information.
So in some ways, I did my research
growing up in a house with parents
who grew up during The Depression.
And so I knew that my mother's
father had lost his job.
They had to take in
borders to pay the rent.
That she was a maid.
That she couldn't go to college,
the college she wanted to go to,
because there is no money.
So the Kit story grew out
of the stories I lived with,
and then in terms of the Samantha
stories, I knew that story
because of my old pal,
Eleanor Roosevelt,
with whom I was lucky enough
to fall in love when I was 11.
So I read everything and still do
read everything I can get my hands
on about her and her childhood.
So I knew with that
childhood was like.
Doing research is breathing.
When I was writing about Josefina,
my family and I went to New Mexico
for about five summers in a row.
I had one chair in the Southwest
reading room that I kind
of started to think of his mine.
If somebody else was in it,
I was kind of a little fussed
about it, to tell you the truth.
And then I would, you know, sidle
up to a lady in the grocery line.
You know, hi, hi, and I try
to strike up a conversation
and then try to wheedle my way
to be invited to her house,
so that I can ask her, you know,
what did your mother tell you
that her mother had told her mother.
Her mother was the most important
thing for somebody to know?
So research is talking to
people and going places
and trying things in
addition to reading.
But I think it's just
being aware of.
I think it's just being aware of.
That said, I'm also lucky enough
that there are researchers
at American Girl who can, and have,
told me exactly how
much it would've cost
to have a man's shirt dry cleaned
in December in Cincinnati in 1934.
So there are researchers who can
answer very specific questions
for me, as well, he and be
sure my facts are accurate
and right on the money.
But you kind of had to do research
to find out what you don't know.
You know, you had to do
a lot of research to find
out what questions you need to ask.
So I love it.
That's my favorite thing.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Oh, I would to Williamsburg
so many times people started
to mistake me for one
of the docents.
Truly, so many times, and
you know, my daughter --
our daughter was just
learned to walk at that time,
and so the poor thing, I'd
swing her in a backpack,
drive down to Williamsburg, walk all
around, you know, and everything.
She learned to walk at
Williamsburg, you know,
pushing the stroller
in front of her.
So yes, I went to Williamsburg,
many, many times.
That's an enchanting -- that's
a very enchanting place to go,
and that's a wonderful way to
gather impressions, as well.
So in fact, just for my birthday,
just last month, my husband
and I kind of cooked up this flimsy
excuse that we had to go back
to New Mexico, because I'm writing
that mystery about Josefina.
So we were drinking
in the atmosphere.
I mean, that was essential research.
Sure, so research is
whatever you want it to be.
Any other questions?
Oh, Eddy?
>> What's the difference between
being an editor and being a writer?
>> Valerie Tripp: Oh, yes, oh, Eddy.
First of all, it's very humbling,
and I am embarrassed to admit
that I thought, oh, you know,
I've been dealing with editor
since I was 23 years old.
I've been dealing with
editors for 40 years.
So I know what it takes
to be an editor.
No, I don't.
Editing is a completely different
art, a completely different art,
and it has been very
hard to learn how to --
editors are like psychiatrists
who help you say what
you really meant to say.
They help you lead the life
you really meant to lead,
and I turned -- I'm way
too hands-on as an editor.
And has been a very difficult
task to learn how to say
to a person I don't
understand this part.
Could you do it again?
It's also very, very hard for
me, because I know how hard it is
to write a paragraph,
and I don't want --
it pains me physically to ask a
writer to cut a paragraph out.
You're thinking oh, my gosh.
I know how hard it was to do.
Look at that fabulous metaphor she's
got going in there, and I just --
I hate asking a person
to cut things.
You have to be a little -- I don't
mind cutting my own stuff is much
as I mind cutting things that
other people have written.
So that is a very steep
learning curve, and it's like --
not to mix my metaphors, but
it's the Myth of Sisyphus
for me, that learning curve.
That I get part way up and slip
right back to the bottom again.
Very, very hard.
Very hard to do.
It has taught me to be
extremely grateful to my editors.
I'm so grateful that they are
willing to dive into the muddy pit
of my story with me and try
to help us both climb out.
I'm very grateful.
So I've got a lot of learning to do.
Right here.
>> Could you describe how the dolls
and the merchandise and the clothes
and all of that, how that --
>> Valerie Tripp: Works?
>> Works together with the books.
What's the chicken and what's
the egg, and how does that aim
for the psyche of the child?
You know, how that works together.
>> Valerie Tripp: Yes, well,
one thing about for the psyche
of the child is that nobody has ever
really sort of combed the depths
of the mystery of how the
child interacts with the doll.
It's pretty cool, you know?
Sometimes you're the dolls mother,
and then sometimes you are the doll.
Then sometimes you're
her best friend.
It's very fluid, and so I
think that's a fabulous play,
because that teaches you empathy.
You know, you're becoming
someone else and trying
to imagine how another
person would feel.
So I think doll play is great.
The way it works with me
for the stories is sometimes
one thing comes first,
and sometimes the other.
So I love to tell the story I
was just telling somebody before
that with Kirsten, I
did a lot of research.
Kirsten's name is going
to be Rebecca,
and she was going to be Norwegian.
So I did a lot of research
about Norway's, you know,
getting into the food, everything,
and then one day Pleasant,
who is the head of Pleasant Company
who started American girl called me
and said, you know,
hold the presses.
She said, "Rebecca has to be Kirsten
now, and she has to be Swedish,
because I have found the most
adorable Swedish sweater."
So, but then in the case of like
Kit, for example, I was able to say
to the product developers, you
know, Kit wants to be a reporter.
So you've got to make
a miniature typewriter.
So sometimes the story dictates what
the product will be, and sometimes,
the product has a big
influence on the story.
The appearance of the
doll is, of course,
very dependent on where she's from.
When we were writing about
Josefina, I had a board of advisors,
and one of my advisors was a man
named Philippe Mirabal [assumed
spelling], and Philippe they
cut off a chunk of his own hair,
and we sent Philippe's
hair to the doll factory,
so that we can see exactly what
color hair Josefina should have.
So I always think that
Philippe a goes bald,
we're just going to
buy a Josefina doll.
He just Scotch tape that hair
right back on top of his head.
So sometimes the appearance and
the stuff about the doll has to do
with where she's from and when
she's from, and then other times,
it grows out of the story and who
she is and what her character is.
And I always like to say
to children, you know,
what Kit's father gives
her this typewriter,
and when your parents
give you something,
it's not just the object, okay?
We've got to look at levels.
It's not just a typewriter
Kit's dad is giving to her.
You saying to her, "I think it's
great that you want to be a writer."
And when your mom drives you to
soccer, she's not just saying,
"Yeah, good, I'm glad
you're playing soccer."
She's saying, "You know, I'm really
proud of you for doing this."
So every object has a reason
and a meaning and a depth
and a significance and a symbolism
to it that supports the story,
comes out of the story,
supports the story.
It's very neatly intertwined,
and I also believe firmly
in the synergy of story and object.
I think objects have sort of
energy in and of themselves,
and when you interact with --
that's what virtual will
never replace actual.
That's why we like books.
You know, we like that
weight of it in our hands.
We like the sensual interaction with
the object, and so I think that all
of the things that go along with the
books help the child lift the story
up off the page and, you know, maybe
think of another ending for a book.
Girls are writing to me all
the time saying, "You know,
we get to Molly's birthday party.
You need to tell us what kind of
cake she has at the birthday party."
One girl said, "I personally,
the cake's my favorite thing."
So she wrote a paragraph.
You know, she wrote a whole
chapter of Molly's party
and she was interacting with
that doll and the plates
and the whole thing to extend
that story the way she wanted to,
which I was really thrilled about.
So the objects are
sometimes inspiration,
and sometimes they're inspired by.
It goes both ways.
>> Can you tell us a little bit
about the juxtaposition of writing
for girls, which would feel very
natural, and then writing for boys?
>> Valerie Tripp: You know,
as I said in my speech,
I actually don't think that
at the heart emotionally,
I think the first thing
a child is as a child.
And I think that the task
of childhood is exploration
and experimentation, and I think
that the important thing we have
to say to any child is, you
know, go ahead and try it
and use your imagination.
And I don't really feel that
there's a difference in what we want
to encourage boys to do
and like and what we want
to encourage girls to do and like.
You know what?
I've been thinking about this a
lot, and I think having just said
in my speech that we don't always
write from our own experience,
I think that growing up, I was
always -- you can see in that bio,
I was always the tallest girl,
towering over the other kids.
I never got the sense of
myself as a, you know,
hothouse violet shrinking.
You know, that I never had the idea
that I couldn't do
anything that I tried to do.
So I didn't get the message, I
guess, that girls were different
for boys in their interests or in
what they were going to try to do.
I actually believe, as I said, not
in hardwiring, but in haywiring.
I believe that all of us are
all things at various times,
and it shifts and changes
as we go through life,
and thank goodness that it does.
>> Do little boys respond
to your writing about them?
>> Valerie Tripp: They
like it a lot.
Oh, yeah, they like it a lot.
They think it's very funny,
and they like the adventure,
just the way girls like adventure.
They like the human interaction.
They are familiar with, you know,
personality conflicts and things.
There's no divide.
So I think we create that divide,
and I think maybe that's
a mistake to do.
So are you standing up
because it's time to go?
>> Lawrence Liff: I am.
>> Valerie Tripp: Good, that's okay.
That's great.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible Speech ]
>> Hi everyone.
Before the reception, we
are going to do a drawing
and give away a copy
of Valerie's new book.
So I hope everybody who came and
filled out one of these cards.
If you did not, please
raise your hand,
and we can get you one beforehand,
or if it's just one,
you can have this one.
[ Inaudible Speech ]
>> Valerie Tripp: So before I draw
this, I have to tell you a story.
One time, Addy was a new -- well, I
guess Felicity was a new character,
and I was doing a book
signing in Falls Church,
and a lady came with twins.
So we didn't have enough
mob caps to go around.
So a girl named Dina said, "Okay,
well the extra twin
can have my mob cap."
Three years went by.
Same store that I drew who
was going to win an Addy doll.
Dina won. So if you don't
win today, don't cry.
d
[ Laughing ]
[ Inaudible Speech ]
Jewel. Jewel Stoddard, yay!
[ Applause ]
[ Background Discussion ]
>> Keep going.
>> Valerie Tripp: Just what Jewel
needs, another children's book.
Guiamina Tierado [assumed spelling].
Yay, Guiamina Tierado, who's here
all the way from California..
Good, we got a boy.
Sam Temchun.
>> No, girl.
>> Valerie Tripp: Oh, girl.
Yay, Sam! Oh, see I told
you there's no difference.
Same yay, Samantha.
>> I have a younger brother named
Joe, so we're both [inaudible].
So when I was seven I wrote to
[inaudible] company and asked
if they would consider
making American Boy books,
because my brother liked
reading American Girl books.
So --
[ Inaudible Speech ]
>> Valerie Tripp: Well, I'm
grateful to you and Joe then.
Thank you, Sam.
So we're all finished?
>> Lawrence Liff: I have
one more thing to say.
>> Valerie Tripp: Oh, one.
Okay.
>> Lawrence Liff: Thanks.
Hi everyone, I'm Larry Liff.
I'm the Director of
Development, and my relation is
to the College of Information
Studies.
I'm so thrilled to see you all here
today, and thanks so much again
to Valerie and the
Library of Congress.
You know, the MacLeod
lecture is only made possible
through the generosity of our
donors, and these are the alumni
of the school, the faculty and
staff, the friends and colleagues
of Anne, as well as people in
the community, who understand
and share our value and the
importance of library education
in the study of children's
literature.
This lecture series is such a
wonderful tribute to Anne's work,
her deep passion for the subject,
but also, as a transformative figure
in the scholarly significance
of the field.
The mission of this lecture is
to educate a general audience
on different aspects of children's
literature, to share the expertise
and knowledge of authors
and scholars,
and isn't that where the
reasons that we write literature?
To share our stories with a large
population and a great community?
If you like to Valerie's
talk today and hope to come
in future lectures,
we need your help.
Philanthropic gifts are the sole
reason we can put this event on
and the only way we can
continue to do so in the future.
Information about giving can
be found in your program,
or you can come talk to me.
If anyone is considering supporting
lecture, the college is going
to be offering a copy of
Valerie's new book for anybody
who didn't win one today to any
donor who makes a gift of $100
or more to the college
between now and October 18th,
which is Maryland's homecoming.
So again, please, consider
giving, helping us to continue
to support this great lecture
and honoring Anne Scott MacLeod.
On behalf of the College
of Information Studies,
the Library of Congress, I want
to thank you all again for coming.
Please join us for our reception,
and join me in another round
of applause for Valerie Tripp.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.